Sean Strickland I watch this guy okay
this guy's asking him a question about
lgbtq and he says you would want your
son to be this he I don't care if I
don't have a grandson he's like you're
the FM problem wait a UFC fighter that
grew up with a tough upbringing that you
know the stories about him and his
father he's making more sense than an
educated guy from Canada that's probably
went to the right University and and
this guy's getting more eyeballs and
Logic for no no I agree with this guy
there's something going on on we are
finding each other and when these guys
find each other the enemy fears what is
possible and they don't like people like
us waking up that's where my faith and
confidence comes from because we all
have a line that if you cross we go from
being you know regular people to like
Jordan Peterson says monsters and
certain rage and certain you know person
comes out I think that's the level we
are right now so